I think it is very cool that you
Incorporated actual sign language into
spell casting how did that idea come
about and how easy or difficult was it
to pull that off I was working with a
choreographer and I wanted to root the
spell casting in some sort of language
because I think that smoke casting
actually existed it would be some form
of communication to the space around you
and I have been studying sign language
for about like a year or two now I'm
still not very good but I do know some
signs so I would take a word in sign
language that had to do with the action
of the spell I would modify that sign to
look a little bit more
magical and then that's kind of yeah and
then I would get what I would get